un 15% de las gasolineras en Francia
está teniendo problemas de suministro de
al menos un tipo de combustible así lo
confirmó el gobierno Esto está generando
colas pero también pérdida de tiempo de
los clientes mientras se encuentran una
gasolinera donde llenar el tanque de sus
vehículos la causa primero es el
descuento que hace la petrolera total de
20 céntimos a sus clientes esto se suma
los 30 céntimos que da el gobierno por
lo mismo es esta empresa la que está
sufriendo más esta falta de combustibles
en los últimos días sus demandas han
aumentado un 30% sobre todo en el norte
y en el este del país y la otra causa es
la huelga que realizan los trabajadores
de total en tres de las cinco refinerías
que tiene la empresa en el país por
mejoras salariales ellos dicen que si la
empresa está ganando más dinero en este
momento debiera repartirlo también a sus
trabajadores Francia Entonces ha
comenzado a importar gasolina desde
Bélgica los Países Bajos y Luxemburgo
por lo mismo este fin de semana se va a
permitir el tránsito de camiones
cisterna por las ciudades algo
normalmente está prohibido y también
Francia ha comenzado a tocar sus
reservas estratégicas 18 millones de
toneladas de combustible que representan
el consumo de Francia durante 90 días
además las autoridades han pedido los
franceses que no llenen el tanque si no
es necesario porque eso genera
obviamente más demanda y aseguran que la
situación debe normalizarse dentro de
una semana